[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
changeant maintenant de domaine
d'ailleurs le changement de soi même ou
du monde
c'est le thème de cette édition alors
changeons de sujet avec un membre
nous sommes 7,6 milliards d'être humains
sur cette planète
c'est pas mal non c'est même énorme nous
n'avons jamais été autant à un tel point
que selon le population h 26 bureaux
plus de 6% des êtres humains et ont vécu
dans l'histoire de l'humanité sont
encore en vie aujourd'hui pour faire
comprendre à quel point c'est
hallucinant imaginez que cette salle 200
personnes représente l'humanité donc
avec les dizaines de milliers d'années
de lentilles de la préhistoire des
milliers d'années de l'antiquité
moyen-âge et c est bien les six
personnes devant représenter notre
époque
quelques dizaines d'années un point sur
une ligne le problème c'est que la
consommation d'énergie et de ressources
devrait suivre cette courbe mais en fait
c'est même faux parce que c'est pire que
ça pour chaque personne
cette consommation exponentielle plus
concrètement ça signifie quand deux
siècles la population mondiale a été
multipliée par 7 alors que dans le même
temps la consommation d'énergie l'a été
par 50 et là ça fait peur ça grandit
très vite on fait globalement face à ce
qui s'appelle une croissance
exponentielle
même si certains disent qu'on va se
stabiliser vers à peine 12 milliards
d'être humains
donc ça c'est le mauvais côté de
l'expansion mais on peut leur tournée
pour en faire un bon côté imaginez que
dans les tic ce qui vous rend été
présenté il une idée fantastique qui a
convaincu chacun de vous alors le jeu ça
serait qu' une personne de cette salle
chaque personne de cette salle et un
mois pour convaincre deux personnes donc
ça c'est vous en un peu plus maigres
et donc vous avez convaincu deux
personnes et le jeu c'est que ces deux
personnes convaincre leur tour deux
autres personnes de cette idée et on
continue le jeu est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que au bout de six
mois il y aurait plus de dix mille
personnes convaincues
au bout d'un an ça ferait plus de
grenoble et ses environs qui connaîtrait
l'idée et si on continue imaginons qu'on
puisse continuer l'expérience pendant
deux ans là ça serait presque la moitié
de la population mondiale qui serait au
courant de ça et ça en partant de à
peine 100 personnes ça c'est aussi un
pouvoir de l'expo nancel alors il ya
peut-être un problème encore à ça c'est
que c'est bien beau d'avoir une idée il
faut aussi vouloir et pouvoir
l'appliquer
sinon on ferait face à plein de gens se
disant tiens c'est super cette idée
j'espère que plein de gens là piqueront
à ma place mais moi je vais aller dormir
alors bonne nuit et débrouillez vous
alors pourquoi ces gens ne changent pas
pu y avoir plein de raisons plus ou
moins bonnes parce que le changement
c'est un peu du danger parce que ça va
être de l'inconnu c'est peut-être
potentiellement moins bien c'était mieux
avant ou alors parce qu'on va s'attaquer
à ce que certains appellent des libertés
individuelles
ou alors parce que tous ces systèmes
physiques dans l'univers tend vers une
énergie potentielle minimale pour
stabiliser son équilibre ce qui se
traduit chez les humains par un
phénomène bien connu sous le nom de
flemme
alors certains espèrent experts ont
fustigé cette flamme ils vont expliquer
que pour sauver la planète ou juste en
fait pour limiter la casse il faudrait
boycotter 95% des entreprises ne peuvent
rien acheter neuf ne plus produire de
déchets pour finalement complètement
changer de système économique
le système de transport de manière de
consommer de penser d'agir de manger
bref de changer totalement nous comme
l'ensemble de l'humanité et ce jour au
lendemain et je suis d'accord il
faudrait faire ça néanmoins je pense que
presque personne où personne n'est prêt
à le faire même en connaissant les
raisons de cela et ce même en ayant une
flemme disons modéré puis dire que les
gens doivent changer n'est pas vraiment
une
une solution en plus je parle beaucoup
d'experts donc peut-être vous pensez à
des scientifiques à des chercheurs
peut-être que vous avez en tête la super
blague qui dit que des chercheurs qui
cherchent on en trouve mais des
chercheurs qui trouvent on en cherche
alors bizarrement ça fait pas trop rire
les chercheurs et en plus ça peut être
un peu paradoxal parce que c'était de
cette même personne qui ne change pas
parce que justement elle pense que c'est
à la science d'apporter toutes les
solutions les scientifiques vont trouver
des solutions ils vont trouver
on va trouver alors je suis docteur en
mathématiques appliquées à l'imagerie
médicale et je vous le dis ne comptez
pas sur nous enfin ne compte pas que sur
nous il ya des des journalistes qui
n'aide pas vraiment à combattre ce
cliché
parce qu'ils vont titre est par exemple
des nouvelles technologies de batteries
une solution d'avenir fantastique au
stockage de l'énergie
ou alors les piles à hydrogène le
carburant vert du futur maintenant je
pense pas qu'ils aient cueilli qui vont
vraiment écrire ça si on fait alors j'ai
eu la chance de parler à des doctorants
qui travaillent sur des nouvelles
technologies de batteries ou des piles à
combustible hydrogène et je leur ai
demandé est ce que c'est une solution
d'avenir et ils m'ont répondu on n'en
sait rien donc en fait l'idée c'est pas
que s'ils sont super inquiétant c'est
que c'est super difficile de voir si une
technologie va avoir un impact important
sur la société et je pense que ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que il n'y a pas de
solutions technologiques miraculeuse
d'ailleurs par définition la science
n'est pas miraculeuse même si elle peut
être merveilleuse alors les
scientifiques en certain rôle à jouer
mais il faut comprendre qu'il ya des
erreurs qui ont été faites dans
l'histoire de l'humanité qui sont
surfaites par exemple après la seconde
guerre mondiale il eu le souhait pour
tenter de relancer l'économie et
l'industrie et poursuivre dans une
certaine idéologie de fabriquer plein de
voitures et de réduire en même temps les
infrastructures pour les transports en
commun donc ça je sais pas si ça rend
vraiment relancer l'économie
mal placé pour le dire
je pense que ça a pas mal relancé la
production de dioxyde de carbone
alors donc les scientifiques
je le dis sans un rôle à jouer mais tout
le monde
un politicien un dirigeant du cac 40
ingénieurs en étudiant fauché une merde
célibataire surchargé donc pas les mêmes
responsabilités les mêmes pouvoirs les
mêmes privilèges mais chacun peut agir à
son échelle avec un impact fort
personne ne peut aider tout le monde
mais tout le monde peut aider quelqu'un
qui regarde les speakers qui sont passés
ce n'étaient pas que des scientifiques
et ils n'ont pas que parler de sciences
il pourtant
chacun essaie d'apporter sa vision ses
idées ses solutions pour pour c'est
demain un peu la preuve que pour penser
demain il ya un spectre large de
compétences et de domaine à avorter mais
non je vais essayer d'être un peu plus
concret il ya un américain qu'elle vient
jour l'idée fois les géniales de mettre
sa santé en danger en mangeant tous les
jours dans une célèbre chaîne de fast
food américain et il en a fait un
documentaire alors son but c'était de
montrer qu'en diminuant la taille de
certaines boissons et en proposant pas à
chaque fois le menu le plus gros on
faisait déjà un pas contre l'obésité et
il a réussi l'a gagné son combat et
quelques kilos
il ya certains cadres importants de la
société qui ont démissionné et il ya une
prise de conscience donc regarder super
size me mais ne faites pas ça parce
qu'il ya des meilleurs moyens de changer
qui sont eux un peu plus bénéfiques pour
la santé
par exemple vous pouvez vous formez à
l'utilisation d'un défibrillateur
vous allez perdre entre guillemets trois
heures de votre vie mais peut-être que
vous en ferez vous ferez gagné des
dizaines d'années de via à quelqu'un
là on est sur des petits changements
mais qui peuvent avoir des vraiment
grandes conséquences
d'ailleurs c'est vraiment une idée que
j'aimerais apporter à ce vous retenez
dans ce tedx c'est que des petits
changements peuvent avoir des grandes
conséquences
il ya même une théorie mathématique
basée là-dessus reste
aurez-vous je vais pas trop parler de
maths mais sachez que ça s'appelle la
théorie du chaos et vous la connaissez
peut-être sous le nom d'effet papillon
donc l'effet papillon pourquoi ça
s'appelle comme ça parce que c'est
l'idée que un papillon qui bat des ailes
peu à des milliers de kilomètres de là
provoquer un typhon alors c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué que ça mais l'idée
c'est toujours pareil c'est qu'on va
modifier des petites conditions
initiales dire des petits paramètres on
dit qu'en fait on va perturber les
conditions initiales et ses petits
changements vont avoir des grandes
conséquences et des conséquences
totalement différente pour illustrer sa
je vais parler de l'exemple historique
de la théorie du chaos qui est la météo
vous êtes en forêt avec votre famille
vous vous baladez vous faites peut-être
du vtt comme ça été dit et tout d'un
coup il ya une tempête et là quelqu'un
va dire ah mais j'avais regardé la météo
a émis un gros soleil du coup pourquoi
c'est pas parce que les météorologues
sont des gros nuls 1 vous dis parce que
la météo c'est un phénomène chaotique
c'est à dire qu'à un moment il ya des
trucs quelques dixièmes de degrés
celsius j'en change et à des centaines
de mètres dans un nuage et ça totalement
modifié la météo à une heure après les
météorologues qui peuvent capables ils
peuvent être capable de prévoir s'il va
y avoir un hiver froid ou chaud mais
c'est très difficile de prévoir le temps
précisément à cause de ça d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que c'est pas bien de
regarder la météo a plus de trois jours
et en fait vous regardez la météo à plus
de 5 ou 7 jours c'est aussi pertinent
que de regarder un horoscope donc changé
et arrêter de regarder la météo à plus
de 5 ou 7 jours et si vous le faites
arrêter de regarder les horoscopes là
c'était des petits changements qui ont
des grandes conséquences et des
conséquences qui sont parfois imprudent
prévisible alors je parle beaucoup de
conséquences mais parfois on n'est pas
obligé de parler de conséquences
enfin on peut juste parler de bon sens
vous choisissez de prendre l'ascenseur
pour monter deux étages alors vous êtes
en bonne santé que vous avez pas de
bagages si vous préférez utiliser
d'électricité qui vient peut-être d'une
centrale nucléaire
juste pour vous faire porter plutôt que
d'utiliser votre corps qui est fait pour
ça en fait qui ne demande qu'à ça en
fait ça même des gens on m'a dit qu'ils
prennent l'ascenseur pour descendre mais
là j'ai pas je sais pas j'ai pas trop
d'explications à ça quand vous
choisissez de prendre la voiture pour
faire une voiture à essence pour faire 2
km ou moins c'est que vous préférez
utiliser du pétrole qui vient peut-être
d'arabie saoudite de russie ou en
traversant l'océan du venezuela et qui
va être affiné et brûlées dans un moteur
à plus de 400 degrés celsius tournant là
plusieurs milliers tours/minute et tu
vas trop jeter sous forme de monoxyde de
carbone de dioxyde d'azoté particules
fines que des substances mortelles
le tout en occupant plus de 10 mètres
carrés d'espacés publics dans une cage
en métal qui va peser plus d'une dizaine
de fois votre poids plutôt que de faire
20 minutes de vélo dix minutes même de
vélo dix minutes 20 minutes de marche à
pied pour une fois faire un peu de sport
arrêtez d'être assis et prendre l'air et
en plus avec un peu de chance vous irait
même plus vite
alors moi je trouve qu'on a suffisamment
d'addiction comme ça donc autant que
possible réduisant nos dépendances à
l'ascenseur et à la voiture n'importe
qui peut faire des changements simples
comme ça alors il faut arrêter d'avoir
peur de du changement pour une raison
c'est que vous changez tout le temps
constamment
chaque jour vous perdez 50 milliards de
cellules
mais rassurez vous ils vous ont gagné à
peu près autant chaque jour
ça veut dire que littéralement entre le
début et la fin de set 6 vous ne serez
plus la même personne
un plus la même personne c'est un peu
naïf mais j'aime me dire que pour rester
dans le thème de cette édition penser
demain pour changer le monde de demain
il faudrait peut-être d'abord changer un
peu soi-même aujourd'hui alors je vois
passer
petit changement comme une révolution je
les vois comme un déclic comme un début
pas ce qu'on peut me dire oui et changer
la société
le seul pouvoir qu'on a c'est de voter
et voter finalement c'est pas un gros
pouvoir avec ce qu'on voit actuellement
mais en fait ce que je vous compreniez
c'est que chaque geste du quotidien peut
être un vote
un vote pour ce que vous voulez être
pour ce que vous voulez que la société
soit l'échelle ce que vous mangez ce que
vous consommez ce que vous achetez ce
que vous lisez ce que vous écoutez ce
que vous regardez sont des choix plus ou
moins conscients et qu'ils peuvent avoir
un impact bien plus fort que vous le
pensez s'il ya un choix collectif de
boycotter une émission de télé c'est à
dire qu'il n'y aura pas d'audience pas
d'audience pas de publicité intéressait
pas de publicitaire intéressé par
d'argent pour la chaîne pas d'argent
pour la chaîne pas d'émission avec un
type qui me dépasse dans les sous
vêtements de ses invités plus
sérieusement quand vous achetez un objet
demandez vous pourquoi vous l'avez
acheté interrogez vos désirs interrogez
vos envies interrogez vos pensées
demandez-vous où il a été fabriqué
comment par qui dans quel but
où ira l'argent investi dans quelles
conditions et posez-vous ces mêmes
questions pour les composants qui le
définissent pour les matières premières
et vous comprendrez vite que souvent
vous n'aurez pas une réponse exhaustive
à ces questions mais s'interroger c'est
déjà changé de toute façon avec le
changement climatique
ça c'est un autre changement qui est un
peu moins sympa avec la disparition des
espèces des individus non humains
l'extinction des la disparition des
ressources
il y aura des conséquences importantes
je reparle encore de conséquences
importantes
là c'est juste des petits trucs de moins
en moins de territoire vivable des
migrations en masse des catastrophes
naturelles en pagaille une agriculture
impossible des vagues de chaleur
intenable
les choix que nous n'aurons pas fait
nous retomberons dessus comme des choix
encore plus dur à faire
nous n'aurons plus le choix
faire des choix c'est un peu s'il na
pali sade mais je pense que pour gagner
il faut jouer mais il faut surtout jouer
avant la fin du jeu et comme disait
winston churchill
mieux vaut prendre le changement par la
main avant qu'ils vous prennent par la
gorge
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]